[Music]
my name is Ellen I'm a research
assistant at Kong leaf development lab
this is where we do our deception
studies and here we play three games
with the kids you've been doing such a
good job and we got off to such a good
start that I kind of want to give you a
prize so I've actually picked one out
just for you so you can open it up and
I'm going to get data for the next
activity
do you like your eyes yes children begin
to tell lies at two years of age and
these kind of Lies tend to for their own
benefits such as to cover your
transgression or to gain some benefits
for themselves but with increased age
they become more and more likely to have
white lies to spirit other people's
feelings or to be blind ironically even
though we morally do not condone life in
general but lying is essential part of
our everyday life and imagine a world
that nobody lives and that's going to be
incredibly crude the world let's try
this one getting a fire on lower lower
right see uh-oh ELISA this is the moment
of truth this is the flash ground yet we
are playing so you can guess this one
right that candy bag is yours but if you
can't guess it right then I get to keep
that bag of candy for you know what I
think I hear my phone ringing oh okay
okay on one second I'll be right back
don't look at the car you can make your
guests might get off and then just be
committed
[Music]
oh my god Elise I'm so sorry and you I
heard it ringing it was my mom super
important so sorry okay
so let's get back to it
these women I was out of the room did
you peek at the card mm-hmm can you sit
for you're handsome for me thank you say
yes or no
[Music]
okay once young Jolyon under seven years
of age line you can ask for abortions
and then you can easily detect they
actually lie just lied because they
cannot cover up the initial line
children's ability to tell lies at a
young age tend to be indicative of their
other abilities such as the ability to
community too many of the others they
are ability to understand the other
people's emotions and the ability to
know the difference between what they
know what they feel and whether others
know others feel and these abilities are
essential for us to interact with each
others so having the ability to tell
lies is really a milestone to tell you
your child is doing okay so they are
telltale signs of lying or truth telling
that we cannot see with our naked eye
but computer vision can see we used
technology developed by emotions and
this program basically using computer
vision to learn to detect your subtle
muscle movements on your face and by
looking at the combinations or patterns
of your muscle movements we can tell
whether or not you are experiencing real
emotion or you are faking emotional
[Music]
Oh